also we will have a uh a hotline number
later for you
if you have been sexually assaulted at
the ellen degeneres program
which uh everyone that has ever worked
there has apparently been goosed
in the dressing room at the lng what is
going on
at ellen she's out there dancing
and in the back it's a free-for-all
apparently it's the marquis de sade
is running around the dressing room and
ellen terrifying
the employees i thought she was just a
[ __ ]
that's what i thought i know people that
know her but apparently it's not that
there's sexual deviance running around
and they're making people feel
uncomfortable they're sick get up how
many people
have been sexually assaulted and ellen i
won't stand for it
i won't stand for this anymore
do i like the show more now that's the
question
do i like it more now that i know that
ellen degeneres has been running a rape
room
in the back of her fun
positive show
i mean more trouble at the ellen
degeneres show former employees make
sexual misconduct allegation dozens
dozens of former ellen degeneres show
employees accuse multiple executive
producers of sexual misconduct
harassment and assault
wow degeneres apologize as an ongoing
internal investigation
into toxic worst workplace allegations
revealed
deficiencies related to the show's
day-to-day
management
nearly a dozen former employees accused
head writer and executive producer
kevin lehmann of sexual misconduct
including
groping making sexually explicit
comments
and behaving inappropriately at a
company party well
it's a party while layman said he denied
any kind
of sexual impropriety multiple former
employees
accused executive producer ed glavin of
being handsy with women
and leading the team by creating a
culture of fear and intimidation though
glavin did not comment
36 former employees
independently corroborated incidents of
sexual misconduct
36 employees in ellen
the friendly show where the woman dances
in china they don't even call it they
call it dancing lady in china
so 36 former employees that dancing lady
have been sexually assaulted and i'm not
trying to make light of that
although it is my job to and also i am
but the point is
i'm not making light of the sexual
assault i'm making light of the fact
that while it's going on
ellen is bringing out sloths to make
kristen bell
giggle
you expect that type of stuff in certain
environments fox news
i don't even think there were 36 people
at fox news
and roger ailes was just running around
grabbing blondes and
throwing them out of windows for months
that guy ran that place with an iron
fist
i mean bill o'reilly was just taking
women's head and holding them in fish
tanks
and you still didn't get to 36 women
bill o'reilly paid like 38 million
dollars
to somebody god only knows what that
guy did what did you do to someone to
pay him 38 million kill them
i mean that's the type of settlement you
get when you murder somebody
and still i don't believe and i could be
wrong but i don't believe they had 36.
i mean it's wild and you know they
complained ellen about it they were like
you know uh kevin got a little handsy or
ed got a little handsy with me
and you know she just looked at them
with that stone face because she's in
the cia
and she's an asset uh uh who is the the
uh jorge
campos jorge raymond yeah jorge capos i
do this all the time jorge ramos a guy
at univision
compost the only guy to meet
stephen paddock goes and is interviewed
on
ellen it's a little weird
couple that which she's sitting next to
george w bush and they yuck it up
yucking it up about all their fun days
at abu ghraib
and she's you know there's all kinds of
emails that came out where you know
hillary clinton's on the show promoting
uh you know whatever war
that she wants to have on a wednesday
afternoon and alan goes come on in
i'll work in between the dance and the
kristen bell sloth and you can tell us
why we gotta bomb syria hill come on in
come on down and in the back we're gonna
have women running for their lives
that's why hillary looks so comfortable
on the show because behind the scenes
you could hear the screams of women
being muffled
huh that's why you gotta dance and they
turn the music up so you don't hear
help that's the official shot
official sign of the ellen degeneres
show huh
you know ellen looked at them with that
stone cold wolf-like face she has
and she was like [ __ ] dance
and the girl's like what and ellen goes
dance
and they had to go
it was ellen was a trailblazer she came
out on her abc sitcom which also sucked
but she came out and that was good i
applaud that
and then she joined the cia that i don't
live
and then she uh did a show where she
danced
engaged in inane meaningless horseshit
conversation
and uh behind the scenes uh people were
being chased around with hammers
so it's been she's gone quite full
circle
uh she did suffer a lot of
discrimination when she came out of the
closet
and apparently that sat with her and she
said what if we just
you know we just set up a daytime talk
show and in uh
in the background we'll have uh abu
ghraib
it's a regular abu ghraib in the ellen
degeneres dressing room
you got dogs people naked stacked
together
get up abu grave photos right now this
is what's going on in ellen
this is what's going on in the back of
ellen
abu grave torture hit image
bring bring that up this is
these are the segment producers at ellen
if you're a segment producer at ellen
this is how it works out for you
and then your parents call you and
they're real proud of your big la job
and you go yeah mom there they are
go back go get the guy with the they're
electrocuting the guy
look at this yeah this by the way
yeah that's an intern at ellen it came
in late
that's an intern at ellen that uh was
got stuck in traffic on a 405.
and you know ellen walks by that and
says nothing
she walks by and says nothing because
she's got to go sit in a chair
and do a jig with dick cheney
henry kissinger's coming on they're
going to do the charleston
what's going on over there i want
answers god darn it
she's never had me on
what a fun interview let's practice
uh the interview you be ellen we come
out we dance we sit right down
okay hey thanks for doing the show hey
how are you there's like three people
being raped in the back you know about
that
no i have no idea hoof all right anyway
so i have a podcast
called the tin dylan show
so i want to get into this too i want to
get into this because this is a show
with a lot of serious matters and i
don't want to kid around anymore
um you can get this off by the way can
you imagine by the way
hey q anon where were you did you care
did anyone care about this
did anyone care about this when we
brutally tortured people many of them
were innocent
did that bother anyone by the way that's
not a conspiracy theory that's united
states government
by the way that's the united states
government designed by
uh top down by cheney rumsfeld the whole
crew
in league with psychologist mitchell and
jason we we
took people many of them off off uh we
grabbed them off a battlefield maybe
they were terrorists maybe they weren't
maybe they were confused kids
and then we sent them to blackside
shipped them all over the world and
tortured them
so again that's not chrissy teigen doing
that
that's your government